I went to a practitioner who did live blood cell analysis. He found bacteria in my blood that
could only originate from mouth for the vaginal tract. Given the whole body thermogram you did
for me in your office showed a hotspot at a bold defect in my jaw. It made sense to take another
look at that. After the thermogram I did have a colon beam scan done at a biological dentist. They
called nothing. He recommended a dentist that would do an ozone injection at the site to clear out
any possible bacteria. The research I can find is mostly about the IV ozone infusions, not about
localized objections. What I found advises caution because of toxicity to ozone. What are your thoughts
on the localized injection? I have a consult with the dentist this week. I
toxicity to ozone is very very rare. I would even bring that into consideration. Doing a localized
injection of ozone is the wise thing to do. I think your dentist is exactly right. This is
exactly what should be done. That's what I'm talking about.